ça va être dur pour lui et ce créteil ce
soir en roumanie l'équipe de handball de
la ville la plus sportive de france elle
est connue comme ça joue la demi finale
de la coupe des coupes d'europe
sans stéphane huet son meneur de jeu qui
s'est blessé à l'entraînement mais
cristolien c'est ainsi qu'on appelle les
gens de de créteil ont à faire face aux
redoutables dinamo de bucarest
en attendant les résultats de cette
rencontre faisons le point sur les
raisons du succès de l' us créteil
l'histoire du club commence en 1964 mais
son ascension fulgurante est beaucoup
plus récente en disant créteil va passer
du niveau régional
à une demi finale de coupe d'europe
gravissant chaque année tous les
échelons de la hiérarchie fait il fait
aujourd'hui figure de club phare du hand
français
mais les succès n'arrive pas par hasard
le club a su se structurer
cet homme est responsable d'essilor une
grosse société d'optique qui emploie 12
cents personnes à créteil il ya dix ans
il a pris en main les destinées du club
aujourd'hui il est vice-président et le
numéro 1 s'appelle jean claude tactique
le frère de bernard industriel
publicitaire banquiers le club est
aujourd'hui diane encadré ajoutez à cela
un nouveau palais des sports et vous
avez peut-être la recette du miracle
cristolien iliaque de travail est à la
recherche de parts de technicien au
départ de bon voire de très bons
techniciens et puis également deux
dirigeants de telle manière à ce que
dans le fond on travaille dans un club
parce que comme dans une entreprise
sinon début du mois au fur à mesure que
l'on s'élève dans la hiérarchie
l'autre carte maîtresse du club c'est la
ville elle-même sacré l'an dernier ville
la plus sportive de france créteil mise
beaucoup sur ces clubs infrastructures
modernes aide financière le budget
sportif représente 12% du budget
municipal football athlétisme natation
créteil et compétitif dans plusieurs
disciplines
mais le handball fait partie des
priorités municipales reste à savoir si
le public va suivre le football attire
beaucoup plus un public régional alors
que nous on a tendance à attirer un
public plus cristolien bon il n'ya pas
très longtemps que l'on n'a à notre
disposition ce palais des sports ce qui
signifie que depuis qu'on l'a on a eu
des rencontres où la publicté saliens
venus nombreux
alors bien sûr en quart de finale et en
huitièmes de finale mais également dans
les rencontres amicales créteil n'est
pas seulement une ville nouvelle c'est
aussi une ville jeune un potentiel
d'avenir sur lequel le club comptait
pour le handball
on dénombre aujourd'hui 21 une équipe de
jeunes modèle avoué les écoles de en
yougoslavie ou la technique et
l'encadrement sont homogène des équipes
poussins à l'équipe vedette mais pour
l'instant on n'en est pas là avec un
budget annuel de 2 millions
huit cent mille francs on est loin des
budgets de foot ou même du basket
professionnel